[Music]
the david pakman show at david
pakman.com so on the program before i've
done several videos sort of analyzing
and dissecting these absolutely
ridiculous and embarrassing very
ignorant interviews that our president
has given and most of those interviews
have been a pretty huge interest to the
audience which is good i mean it's good
that when i do
a dissection of an interview and really
go into detail about what is being
implied what is said what is not said
that the sort of broader circumstances
in which these interviews are taking
place it's good that that does well
because it just signals that the
audience is actually interested in going
beyond just the most superficial stuff
that happens in american politics a lot
of those interviews have gotten you know
five hundred thousand views on youtube
seven hundred and fifty thousand some i
think some of those analyses have even
gotten like a million views on youtube
those all pale in comparison to an oval
office interview that donald trump just
gave to ABC News and George
Stephanopoulos that doesn't require
really anything beyond just the most
superficial analysis because at its core
what Donald Trump is saying is that he's
willing to collude with foreign
countries that are interested in helping
him win the 20/20 election Donald Trump
sang to the extent that colluding with
foreign countries is criminal whether
it's conspiracy to collude or a volume
ins violations receiving things of value
he's interested in doing that in 2020 if
anybody has dirt on potential twenty
twenty opponents for him and he wouldn't
go to the FBI so let's just kind of back
up and and set this up George
Stephanopoulos asking Donald Trump about
given everything that happened in 2016
if countries came to you in 2020 with
dirt on your opponents
would you do let's check out the first
piece of this absolutely insane video
your son Don jr. is up before the Senate
Intelligence Committee net today and
again he was not charged with anything
in retrospect that way not only wasn't
he charged if you read it with all of
the horrible fake news I mean I was
reading that my son was going to go to
jail this a good young man that he was
going to go to jail and then the report
comes out and they didn't even say they
heard leave adoption and you're going to
the FBI when he got that II okay let's
put yourself in a position you're a
congressman somebody comes up and says
hey I have information on your opponent
do you call the FBI I don't think I mean
from anyone you do I've seen a lot of
things over my life I don't think in my
whole life I've ever called the FBI in
my whole life I don't you don't call the
FBI you throw somebody out of your
office you do whatever I Gor got a
stolen briefing book he called the FBI
well that's different the stolen
briefing but this is and stuff this is
somebody that said we have information
on your opponent Trump's right the the
initial information that he was offered
in the Trump Tower meeting might not
have been stolen but then he asked
Russia to steal information he's acting
like the theft of the information is
relevant but he asked for information on
Hillary and the DNC to be illegally
hacked and stolen can you obtain those
thirty thousand missing emails you'll be
rewarded for it Russia if you're
listening we'll play that clip later on
but let's go back just a few seconds
here in the George Stephanopoulos
interview and pick it back up well
that's different to stolen briefing but
this isn't a stuff this is somebody that
said we have information on your
opponent oh let me call the FBI give me
a break
life lesson whatever our director says
that's what should happen the FBI
director is wrong your campaign this
time for added foreigners if Russia if
China if someone else offers you
information on upon it should they
accept it or should they call the FBI I
think maybe you do both I think you
might want to listen I don't there's
nothing wrong with listening if somebody
called from a country Norway we have
information on your opponent oh I think
I'd want to hear you want that kind of
interference in our elections it's not
an interference they have information I
think I'd take it if I thought there was
something wrong I go maybe to the FBI if
I thought there was something wrong but
when somebody comes up with a poor
research right they come up with a poor
research
oh let's call the FBI the FBI doesn't
have enough agents to take care of it
but you go and talk honestly to
congressmen they all do it they always
have and that's the way it is
it's called Oppo research that's right
he would do it again I mean truly
congratulations to George Stephanopoulos
for this interview a really good job
done by him eliciting all of the things
that we feared most but sort of
anticipated Donald Trump would say about
this even with that speech pattern have
you noticed that when Donald Trump picks
up on a word or phrase that he likes
he'll then use it repeatedly three or
four times in a minute sometimes in this
case Oppo research it's a very unusual
speech pattern that he has which we have
talked about before and we could get
into but it's popping up here again but
to get to the core of the substance here
understand what is taking place
Donald Trump wants us to believe he
didn't collude in 2016 he didn't know
anything about Russian help for his
campaign he had no idea that Russia
wanted him to be elected president over
Hillary Clinton he's totally innocent in
all ways but if this time around Russia
came around with information form about
whoever is going to be his 2020 opponent
he would absolutely take it and he
probably wouldn't go to the FBI with
that nothing says no collusion with
Russia like admitting that you're open
to collusion with Russia in 2020 and
this is why there have to be
consequences because without them not
only does Donald Trump get away with it
in 2016 which he did and he's going to
he actually becomes emboldened like a
little kid and says I do it in 2020 as
well and a conservative David Fromm had
some interesting tweets about this he
says this is like a smoking gun tape of
Nixon confessing on national television
David Fromm tweeted quote like the
smoking gun tape if Nixon had confessed
on national television to a network
anchor instead of in the secrecy of the
Oval Office to his most trusted
aid immediately after this clip of the
George Stephanopoulos interview went
live the hashtag impeach Trump now
immediately trending on Twitter after
the interview was published but I hate
to break it to you if you see this
interview and you see what Donald Trump
says about 2020 collusion with foreign
countries and you're shocked you're
either not paying attention or
deliberately ignorant because if any of
this is shocking you haven't read the
Moller report because all of this
willingness to engage in this type of
behavior is in the report if you go by
the bar letter and then you see Donald
Trump say this you might actually
experience a moment of cognitive
dissonance how can it be bar said no
collusion no obstruction everything's
great the problem was the investigation
not Trump's behavior and then you see
Trump say oh I would I would accept
information about my opponents from
foreign countries in 2020 you might see
that as a contradiction if you just read
within the Moller report you would say
oh yeah that this fits perfectly this is
exactly what Moeller found Donald Trump
and the people around him were willing
to do and were doing and as conservative
David Frum also added on Twitter quote
anybody still believe that Don Jr did
not pre-clear his Trump Tower meeting
with Russian agents with his father
first I've been saying this from the
get-go
whatever criminality does or doesn't
exist in the Trump Tower meeting with
Natalia Veselin let's gaya that's not at
issue here
the question is we were told that Donald
Trump had no idea that that meeting was
being planned that that meeting was
happening that that meeting took place
until much much later and I said from
the get-go that's not believable there's
no way that that's the truth and once
again Donald Trump's answer here so
clear so concise of course yeah I would
take the help and I wouldn't tell the
FBI do any of us believe Trump didn't
know that that Trump Tower meeting was
in development before it took place I
don't believe it for a second why is it
that our president is regularly choosing
other countries over ours Trump says he
would have no responsibility if a
foreign country that's outside of our
democratic
comes to him as a sitting president with
dirt on other candidates that he would
have no responsibility to go to the FBI
that his responsibilities would
effectively be to use that information
to win rather than to try to stop the
foreign interference on our elections
this is an open invitation for other
countries to now try to ingratiate
themselves with Trump in this particular
way it's another signal to Russia or to
whoever else that the door is open
Trump wants to hear from you does nobody
understand that what Donald Trump is
saying in this interview with George
Stephanopoulos is effectively the same
thing as when he said this during the
2016 campaign I will tell you this
Russia if you're listening I hope you're
able to find the 30,000 emails that are
missing I think you will probably be
rewarded mightily by our press let's see
if that happens that'll be next this
interview is that all over again with
different vocabulary and Trump as the
sitting president rather than Trump is
merely a candidate the Oval Office is
not secure the 2020 election is
obviously not safe and the psychology
that we have to apply here is child
psychology I've been reading the book
influenced by Robert Cialdini it's a
real classic from 1984 I've never read
it before I'm finally getting around to
it and the elements in the book based on
the influence and child psychology are
very relevant here when a little kid
gets away with something and their
misdeeds go unpunished
they become emboldened not just to
repeat those misdeeds but to take them
further and see how far they can
actually get this is how children behave
and incredibly this is the psychological
framework that we need to apply to
Donald Trump George W Bush was a
terrible president I don't think he was
a anything like Donald Trump though when
it comes to we have to deal with Donald
Trump like we deal with little kids he
didn't have to deal with Donald with
george w bush like you were dealing with
a little kid you had to deal with them
like you were dealing with a
an individual who has weaponized
neoliberalism and a foreign policy for
political gain but you didn't have to
deal with them like you deal with a
little kid in the way that you do with
Donald Trump and that's what we're
dealing with here are we going to allow
all of this to continue with no
consequences I hope the answer is no
unfortunately I believe the answer is
yes and I want to hear from you what do
you think about this just incredible
incredible interview with George
Stephanopoulos let me know follow me on
Twitter and send me a tweet there at D
Pakman the show is also on twitter at
david packard show the david pakman show
at david pakman.com
[Music]
[Music]
the david pakman show at david
pakman.com today's new members of the
day are paul fowler and derek Benesh
Paul and Derek thank you for being new
members we are mostly funded by viewers
and listeners like Paul and Derek who do
something really simple but really great
they just go to WWE and pokémon calm
they hit the red sign up button if they
want they take advantage of the 40% off
coupon code this is twenty twenty and
then their members it takes under a
minute you're directly supporting your
voting with your dollars and saying
here's a show I want to support let me
help make it financially sustainable and
someone who has been doing that for
almost 5 years as a member is Keith
Victor Keith is today's longtime
sustaining member of the day he's been a
member since 2014 just under five years
and really appreciate not only are
longtime members like Keith but also new
folks like Paul and Derek
ww join pakman.com sign up today takes
under a minute and it is very much
appreciated particularly in the wake of
what appears to be a growing ad
pocalypse 3.0 on youtube we're up to
version 3 now we've really gone through
these development phases quickly and
we're going we're going to be in the
final release version of ad pocalypse
soon a permanent dad pocalypse is what
unfortunately many in the progressive
independent media world are telling me
behind the scenes we have a david pakman
show subreddit which has nearly 11,000
subscribers from our audience now you
can find it at david pakman.com slash
read it people ask me David why don't
you give us the actual reddit address
because it's very long it's reddit.com
slash are slash the david pakman show
it's much easier to just say david
pakman.com slash read it i got a couple
emails last week people saying david
you're trying to get phony traffic to
your website by using a redirect no I'm
not it's just easier to say david
pakman.com slash reddit
it will redirect you to our subreddit a
couple of notable posts and discussions
from the last couple of days that I want
to point out to you once again another
post saying I really want Dave to debate
Candice I don't know if that debate is
ever going to happen a lot of you may
remember that at one point it seemed as
though
Kyle : Sookie and I were going to do a
two-on-two debate with conservative
people I'm lacking in the right words
here conservative individuals Candice
Owens and Charlie Kirk at politican 2018
back in October in Los Angeles it turns
out that I guess they were never really
doing it or at least Candice was not and
then it looked as though I was told by a
third party that was organizing a debate
that Candice Owens had agreed in
principle to debate man we were just
finalizing topics and the dates
tentatively one of those dates was March
18th as you might know looking at a
calendar March 18th has long come and
gone and it doesn't seem at this point
that there's any reasonable opportunity
for me to debate Candice Owens it
doesn't seem that she wants to do it to
be clear it's not me that is holding it
up it is Candice and that invitation
remains open
also from the david pakman show
subreddit a post pointing out that there
is a dave rubin event in Rocklin
California on June 22nd and a couple of
people in the comments said that they
are planning to go and what should they
ask related to the David Pakman show so
let us tell you right now because you
might remember dave rubin recently said
during a public event when asked about
interviewing me that he is not against
it in principle but that i've lied about
him many times he said pac-man has lied
about me a bunch of times and I've asked
for and others have been asking for what
those lies were so if you go to a Dave
Rubin event event and you get the
opportunity to ask a question a question
that will almost definitely get the
video clip on the show is asking dave
rubin
what specific lies did David Pakman tell
about you that would be a really great
question to ask Dave Rubin another great
question for dave rubin
did you watch and if so what did you
think of david pakman joe rogan
of
clearance another question would be
David Pakman has said he would like to
talk to you publicly about the rift
between the two of you are you willing
to do that what preconditions would you
need like if if Dave if David Pakman was
willing to not mention the phrase
marketplace of ideas for example would
you would that be a reasonable
precondition for you to agree to a
conversation with David Pakman do you
think you and David Pakman will ever
reconcile your relationship would be an
interesting question for Dave Rubin and
I think most people in our audience who
are aware of what's going on can
probably come up on their own with other
interesting and relevant questions for
dave rubin at his events video of which
would almost be guaranteed to make it
onto the program presuming the audio and
video quality as good please no vertical
recording record horizontally horizontal
recording much more likely to make it
onto the program these and many other
interesting conversations including
others about policy it's not all about
gossip within the online media community
happening with almost 11,000 of our
viewers and listeners daily on the david
pakman show subreddit david pakman.com
slash our EDD IT yesterday i reported to
you that the donald trump campaign did
some internal polling in a number of key
battleground states and that donald
trump currently according to his own
campaigns internal polls is losing some
major important 2016 battleground states
to most if not all likely democratic
challengers in hypothetical one-on-one
matchups Trump's reaction as I told you
yesterday was Barry the polls say were
doing great period now unfortunately at
the same time that Donald Trump's
campaign was doing internal polling in a
lot of these battleground states
other regular pollsters were also doing
polls in those battleground states and
the public polls say the exact same
thing Donald Trump is not doing
particularly well right now in
one-on-one matchups in a number of key
states including Wisconsin and Michigan
and Pennsylvania and other
now Donald Trump has been presented with
the public polls showing that he's
currently losing to every major 2020
Democratic candidate in these
hypothetical 2020 matchups and Trump has
absolutely lost it and is now claiming
that the polls are totally fake Donald
Trump tweeting in a to tweet tweet storm
quote the fake news has never been more
dishonest than it is today thank
goodness we can fight back on social
media their new weapon of choice is fake
polling capital F in fake capital P in
polling sometimes referred to as
suppression polls they suppress the
numbers had it in 2016 but this is worse
the fake corrupt news media said they
had a leak into polling done by my
campaign which by the way and despite
the phony and never-ending witch-hunt
are the best numbers we have ever had
lie lie lie I mean this is all lies they
reported capital F fake numbers and then
that they made up and don't even exist
all caps we will win again now there are
people on the Left who actually agree
with Trump that the polls are totally
fake and they email me daily and they
tell me Joe Biden's not really winning
the Democratic primary bernie is
actually ahead of Biden or Tulsi is
actually polling ten percent not one
percent you can't believe anything
that's there now I've already talked
about what is and isn't accurate about
polling but the polls are not fake okay
if your evidence is we know twenty
twenty polls are fake because twenty
eighteen polls were totally wrong and
fake and 2016 polls were totally wrong
and fake well the 2016 national polls
were correct they had Hillary winning by
two or three points nationally and she
did of course she lost the electoral
college ultimately because of these 77
thousand votes in three states that were
within the margin of error but the
national polls were right in 2016 the
national polls were basically right in
2018 as well in terms of what would
happen in the Senate with Democrats and
Republicans and what would happen in the
house with Democrats and Republicans so
I don't know what that contingent of the
left is referring to I don't know what
Trump is referring to because what is
now publicly being said in these polls
is the exact same thing
Donald Trump's own internal polls of
these battleground states are saying and
specifically Donald Trump I'm guessing
is referring to a new Quinnipiac poll
from this week where Donald Trump is
losing to every leading 2020 Democrat
let's put the results up on the screen
Trump versus Biden Biden 53 Trump 40
Sanders 51 Trump 42 that's plus 9 for
Bernie Kamala Harris 49 Trump 41 that's
plus 8 for Kamala Warren 49 to 42 over
Trump that's plus 7 Budaj edge and Cory
Booker both 47 to 42 plus 5 over Donald
Trump so normal caveats here number one
is it likely that Donald Trump will end
up with only 40 or 41 percent of the
vote in the 2020 election no Donald
Trump is going to get more unless
there's a serious third party challenger
Trump's going to get more than 40 or 41
percent there are some undecideds
in those numbers that are ultimately
going to vote most likely for either
Trump or the Democratic challenger there
hasn't been is it likely Trump will lose
the popular vote by 7 8 9 10 13 even as
is being shown in the Quinnipiac poll
absolutely not there has not been a
popular vote margin of 10 or greater in
a presidential election since Ronald
Reagan 35 years ago and it would be very
unlikely to happen in 2020 but the main
takeaway here the point is Trump's not
doing well right now 17 months from the
election in a number of battleground
states and nationally against
hypothetical Democratic presidential
nominees who we don't even actually know
who is going to be the nominee yet
there's even a poll this is amazing
there's a poll showing Trump down to Joe
Biden in Texas by four points which is
very close to Trump's net favorability
in Texas which is minus 3 meaning 3
percentage points more see Trump
unfavorably in Texas and then favorably
favorably but I want to every time we do
polling stuff I'm gonna go back to this
because it's so important and I
apologize the people who say I've
said this enough I can't possibly say it
enough I want to caution everyone to be
very careful here we actually want Trump
to think that he's winning because if
Donald Trump really thinks the polls are
fake maybe he really does believe that
he's currently winning in these
head-to-head matchups that's what we
want because a trump who thinks he's
winning and that he has it in the bag
hopefully won't actually go out in
campaign and he'll hang around the White
House and hoe play golf and he'll send
weird tweets out and that will make it
more likely that he ultimately will lose
in 2020 it's really important to
understand that we want to on the one
hand not take for granted no matter what
the polls say you as an individual voter
should operate under the belief that
your vote could swing the election to or
away from Trump in your state okay and
if you take that approach what you would
do on Election Day or as soon as early
voting starts in your state is you would
go and you would vote so no matter what
the polls say assume operate under the
guise that your vote could make the
difference that's number one number two
when it comes to what Trump thinks about
polls the better Trump thinks he's doing
the less he's going to campaign the less
seriously he's going to take the
possibility that he gets defeated in
2020 and we have to remember
systemically we are at a disadvantage
gerrymandering favors Republicans number
one number two the urban-rural divide
favors Republicans in conjunction with
the electoral college number three when
we consider all of the different
possible types of interference that
Donald Trump said to George
Stephanopoulos yesterday he would
welcome in 2020 in terms of opposition
research or Oppo research as Trump calls
it against potential Democratic
candidates there's a whole bunch of
stuff systemically stacked against us
the voter suppression tactics that they
will continue to employ so the better
Trump thinks he's doing the less likely
it is he will take action that might
actually help them in 2020 and that's
something we shouldn't forget either
make sure you're following the David
Pakman show on instagram at david pakman
show follow me while you're there at
David
Pakman lots of great behind-the-scenes
pictures from my trip to Los Angeles
last week and a lot of other great stuff
we will take a quick break and be back
right afterwards the david pakman show
at david pakman.com welcome back to the
david pakman show it's great to welcome
to the program today dr. Sophie Leroy
who is associate professor at the
University of Washington Bothell school
of business great to speak to you today
I appreciate it
oh you're welcome it's great to be on
your show so let's just start when we
talk about the idea of multitasking does
multitasking even really exist or is it
just switching between one task and
another and working on each individually
you're right it actually does not fully
exist like a brain cannot process two
things at the same time so what we do is
actually we switch very quickly between
two things or even more so we feel like
we're multitasking when in fact we're
not we're really against switching back
and forth back and forth really really
fast so in these tests or studies that
are sometimes done where someone is for
example driving a car on a closed course
and there are different obstacles that
pop up and they're simultaneously being
given simple or sometimes not so simple
math problems over the phone it does
seem as though you are both driving and
solving the math problems at the same
time but in some sense are you sort of
putting the driving in an autopilot mode
as you think about the math problems yes
absolutely and that's why you from a
performance standpoint this is really
problematic right because what it means
is that when you do the math problem
while you're driving you're actually not
focused on the road you're not
processing what's going on on the road
and so you can miss queues you can miss
things that are happening your reaction
time is delayed because you need
something else to capture your attention
very you know very fast back on the road
and so when you're not also
on the road and not doing your math
problem you're going to be slower at
your math problem because you're
actually not processing the mask mate so
from a performance standpoint there are
many issues that comes into play due to
the fact that because we're switching
back and forth there is a very small
time period where you're actually not
doing what you're supposed to do so when
we think about how we might sort of do
our work throughout the course of a day
and there is a lot of this what some
people might call multitasking but it's
really switching between tasks back and
forth there's the term attention residue
which is an interesting term which if I
understand correctly relates to the way
in which as you switch between tasks
some of your attention is not fully
there yet or is remaining on the prior
task is that more or less what we mean
when we say attention residue that's
right and so it's a little different
from the multitasking aspect right so
multitasking you're trying to do two
things at the same time and your brain
is switching back and forth back and
forth between those two things
attention residue is a little different
in the sense where it occurs when we
work on something and then we have to
let it go in transition to something
else and in that case our brain cannot
do that either we have a part time
transitioning because we have a hard
time letting go of things that are
incomplete so tensioners does not
necessary
but it occurs when we not fully
satisfied with what we've done it's not
finished we were interrupted in the
middle of that thought process and as we
transition the brain does not want to
let go in part because we have a need
for completion and so those transitions
of those interruptions are really
frustrating our need for completion and
so the brain is going to hold on to it
process what's going on on that task
that we have to put aside and so what
happens is we have actually divided
attention our brain in fact then
multitask attention residue is a form of
multitasking in the sense that it will
go back to the task we're working on
previously and at the same time try to
perform what we're supposed to do in the
present so it's a little different right
in terms of what triggers it but is very
relevant to the workplace as well
because as you think about how we work
right often time we have to
meetings to the next we're working on a
project bloom there's a phone call for
example about a clock from a client or
someone else passing by a colleague who
needs some information and is asking
some questions right so we have to
transition very frequently and Western
systems are just very very hard for the
brain to perform so when I interviewed
Cal Newport a few weeks ago who teaches
computer science at Georgetown I believe
it is he suggests this idea of planned
deep work right focusing on single
intense tasks for long periods of time
because you're reducing the number of
those transitions that you're referring
to and you can be most sort of
productive and thinking most deeply when
you spend a long period of time focused
on one thing of course the practical
issue seems to be that in more and more
jobs 20 30 40 even more than half of the
job can basically be writing emails and
switching to meetings and taking phone
calls and those types of activities so
it seems like that is definitely the
best ideal but it seems very impractical
for many modern jobs at this point in
time absolutely in and that's actually
where my what my research focused on is
kind of assuming that we can't change
our corporate cultures that the neat
kind of this need to get information
right away and can we have a sense of
urgency and that triggers a lot of those
interruptions think about all the
technologies that we have is
facilitating all those interruptions and
so if we assume that those interruptions
are going to stay then how do we cope
with this cognitively right so I'm going
to go back to this idea that what is the
brain in need for what prevents the
brain to transition to move from one
test to another to move from deep work
to deep work is this need for completion
and so what I found in my research is
that when we're in a position where we
are working on something we are
interrupted is incomplete we ask to move
we need to spend maybe a minute to
create what I called ready to resume
plan and so is the same idea of planning
which is a different implementation of
it which is you stop you say okay what
is it that I was doing where am I on my
project what
that I want to do next when I return to
it so especially planning the return is
critical for the grant you feel like
okay I can let go because yes is not
finished but I have a plan that will
allow me to complete and so that sense
of completion is not a threatened as it
is when we just drop everything and
switch so this reduces the need to
resume on what I've shown is that it
actually helps reduce a tension residue
on the next task and as a result
performance will not net next steps
actually increase tremendously I tested
it through different ways you know it
improves the quality of our processing
in terms of processing or if information
people are able to pay more attention it
improves the quality of a decision
making that people engage in it improves
recal of information so they have to
recall information think that they've
read that's also is improved so what was
really interesting is it was a less than
a minute intervention and that led to
huge impact on attention and on
performance now what did you learn about
so if you're if you're writing something
for example and you take a brief break
to look at your email and respond to one
email and then you go right back to the
writing how long is the brain affected
in terms of limited focus after what
might be just 30 seconds to write an
email you know is it's actually it's
huge it's really surprising that how you
know I think it's counterintuitive for a
lot of people how just this very brief
interruption would actually affects you
when you come back right so so the issue
of switching in that case is you switch
to something else than what what happens
when you come back well the brain
basically has to remember where is it
that you where in what kind of thoughts
you can forward your train of thoughts
where you were going and all of those
things by just switching away for a
second then it's going to take you a
long time to remember where you were to
regain the same level of concentration
to remember where you were going and so
it doesn't really mean obviously the
longer the interruption the harder that
switched back
you know the harder it is to switch back
but but even small interruptions
actually are detrimental and so I think
that's where like if you're writing
something and you have to switch even if
it's just a few seconds if you cannot
put couple ideas of what you wanted to
write but even you know often time
people switch because they're kind of
like they don't know what to do next
they're not fully there or they're bored
or it's gonna hurt alright and so just
write like okay I need to write about X
I don't know how to but that's okay and
then you switch and then you return
oh yeah now I know it was about next
yeah that that seems to me to be one of
the most pernicious elements of the sort
of modern task switching availability of
social media at anytime that you want
because at some point in the past if you
are writing something and you have a
very brief you know momentary writer's
block for example you think through it
and maybe in five minutes you're past it
but it's so easy and it's so attractive
to pick up your phone and look at
Facebook or look at Twitter that even
only 45 or 60 seconds later you've now
looked at you know 30 different posts
and thought about 30 different things it
actually seems like it will hinder you
from getting past that writer's block in
a way that maybe just sitting there
quietly for five minutes would actually
let you work through the problem mm-hmm
yes because it makes you busy with
something else and you know very some
research that shows that when we let
things incubate we actually get new
ideas and so it's not that this is less
about doing something else but if that
next task is very cooling very engaging
and even social media to some extent is
you don't have to come in to space to
actually answer your friends while at
the same time think about the ideas that
you were trying to express that way you
know or the problem you're trying to
solve and so we're not getting we're not
getting much by switching in that case
from a pure creativity standpoint or
problem standing standpoint and so it
but is tempting it's easier it felt good
right yes I mean I guess given that it's
just our phones and the apps and the
internet platforms that we use
are designed to keep our attention for
as long as possible how drastic do the
measures need to be that one uses or
employees to avoid those temptations and
distractions I mean should you be
disconnecting your computer from the
internet if it's possible well I mean
it's just not practical like when I'm
preparing for my show all of my source
material is on the internet so I can't
literally disconnect from the internet
but I can put my phone in the other room
for example I'm sorry oh that's right I
agree if I think it's you know but the
more you block what is tempting you know
so it's going to be different things for
different people though I think the
easier it is to not go there when you've
faced with the challenge one thing that
I for example do is I will look at the
time in aside okay for the next 30
minutes I am not touching anything right
right now there's something that I've
that happened to me that I think is
interesting and also relevant to this
kind of shaking out or checking other
devices for longest time I would put my
phone on vibrate so that I would not be
interrupted but then I realized that I
would check it because just in case this
fits cold cold for example just in case
someone ugly text me and I feel like
ending it to answer and I realized that
was actually forcing me to transition
versus if I have it on volume um then I
don't have to worry about it because I
will hear it if someone else to call me
now I have to tell you not a lot of
people call me during the day so wait so
that's also I I know that I can leave
that on volume and not be interrupted
that much but it completely removed all
my checking behaviors because I know if
someone else to reach me I will hear
them I don't have to worry about them
and so I allow myself them to help my
phone with me the other thing that I do
is very much like you I do a lot of in
terms of research I have to be on the
Internet
and I will go I'm going to tell myself I
am NOT going to check the news I'm not
going to check anything outside of work
you know even email for the next two
hours and but that requires discipline
but the interesting part of it is I
think it's discipline that we can learn
and we can train our attention not to
crave for those you know fast
gratification through social media for
example we can train our brain to stick
with what we're doing for a longer time
period
slowly so that's where I think there's
hope but it depends on what we are
willing to do and what what our goals
are yeah it definitely seems like
there's an element in this in which the
brain is sort of like a muscle that can
be strengthened so to speak to be better
at maintaining attention for longer
longer periods of time we have been
speaking with dr. Sophie Leroy who is an
associate professor at the University of
Washington Bothell School of Business
thanks so much for talking to me today
oh it was a pleasure thank you so much
for inviting me the david pakman show at
david pakman.com
[Music]
the david pakman show at david
pakman.com
all right I know that you will know who
I'm talking about right away when I tell
you that a fox news host did something
surprising and that it just made some
sense he told the fox news audience that
they should actually just go and read
the Moller report instead of basing
their opinion on what pundits say
definitely not on what william bars
propaganda letter said and obviously if
you've watched the show before if you've
watched fox news before you would know
that the anchor I'm talking about is
Shepard Smith who has occasionally
pierced the echo chamber of the Fox News
audience take a look
still Nadler says the committee will
have access to some of the special
council's most important files and
that's according to Nadler including
evidence of possible corruption of
justice remember in his 400 plus page
report that everyone in America should
read every one robert muller laid out
ten instances of apparent obstruction of
justice criminal obstruction of justice
potentially by President Trump the
special counselor did not exonerate the
president said if they could have they
would have but they couldn't so they
didn't Muller explained that if he and
his team had confidence that the
President did not commit obstruction
they would have said so he also said
that under Justice Department guidelines
charging the president with a crime was
never an option to him he said the
Constitution requires another process
that's what he said ten instances of
apparent obstruction potentially
criminal did not exonerate Donald Trump
would have said Trump didn't do anything
wrong if they knew Trump didn't do
anything wrong Justice Department
guidelines prevented him from filing
charges other options exist referencing
of course impeachment how bad has the
partisan media industrial complex gotten
that it's newsworthy when someone says
completely uncontroversial but true
things on fox news that happened not to
align with the Republican president's
position and I will go even further by
the way about reading the report I
understand that this is my job and it's
not most people's so reading a four
hundred and fifty page document with
1,500 1,300 however many footnotes I get
that that's not feasible for a lot of
people
but there's another option it's not just
you read the 450 pages or you go by the
4 page bar propaganda letter there is
something called the molar summary of
the report it's not molars report and
it's not bars letter these are executive
summaries of the report law Fair has
these available which we're linking to
if you're watching on YouTube in the
video description down below the molar
report itself is available as a free
audiobook on audible we're linking to
that down below on the YouTube clip do
what Fox News host Shepard Smith says
it's crazy for me to be saying that read
the report listen to the report whatever
I've read almost the entire report I
skipped over some of the parts that were
more kind of like context because if you
already know the context I don't know
that there was that much more for me to
learn from that but I've come away with
much knowledge that I could not have
gotten from William bars letter I
certainly would not have gotten from
Donald Trump's characterization number
one Russia's actions impacted the
election they successfully attacked
election systems period that is in the
report number two there are lots of
things that probably should be criminal
in our country that aren't and what I
mean by that is that there's a lot of
indirect involvement with criminal or
potentially criminal activity that is
not a crime including being a partner to
parties committing crimes even if you
benefit from those crimes even if you
had the sense that they were involved in
those crimes if you're not actively
coordinating those crimes a lot of that
activity is not criminal it probably
should be and the problem we have in
this country and I've said it before and
this is just an example of it on the
street crime side there is way too much
criminalization in our country if you
look at the street crime that gets
people into jail and prison and into the
system there is over criminalization
that has taken place conversely though
on the white-collar side on the
corporate side on the political crime
side it's not criminal enough we don't
have enough criminalization and that is
a broader issue that I've been talking
about for a long time here
and of course a headline takeaway from
reading the actual molar report is that
there is substantial evidence meeting
all three of the requirements for
criminal obstruction of justice by
Donald Trump or in other words on of the
14 possible obstructive acts eight of
those according to the molar report meet
all three of the requirements to be
criminally obstructive acts read the
report okay start the impeachment
inquiry further publicize the contents
it's time I don't know what anybody's
waiting for in the continuing saga of
all the disgusting and immoral and
corrupt things that Republican Senate
Majority Leader Mitch McConnell has done
he has now blocked election security
bills and he just so happens to be
taking money from voting machine
lobbyists nice right this is a separate
story by the way from the totally swamp
filling financial dealings of Mitch
McConnell's wife Elaine Chao and her
conflicts of interest that's gonna have
to be a story for another day
this is other swamp filling nonsense
from Mitch McConnell remember Russian
hackers successfully targeted voting
machines in 2016
voting systems in 2016 they're likely to
do it again in 2020 intelligence
agencies agrees agree the intelligence
agencies of other countries agree
touchscreen voting machines have no
paper trail some have no paper trail
which makes it impossible to verify how
votes were counted if they were counted
who they were counted for and these
electronic voting machines can make it
impossible not only to find but even to
correct problems in many cases there are
ideas about how to stop this both
Democrats and Republicans have actually
proposed some of those ideas in
legislation every single bill that has
been proposed has been stonewalled by
Republican Senate Majority Leader Mitch
McConnell and of course big surprise it
just so happens that the two biggest
voting machine companies have hired
lobbyists at the federal level who
recently have contributed to Mitch
McConnell's reelection campaign for
Senate in Kentucky just delightful right
system we have the two companies I'm
talking about our ES and s and Dominion
voting systems between the two of them
those two companies supply 80% of the
country's voting machines they have very
significant lobbying operations
historically at the state level but
they've now hired federal lobbyists es
NS hired lobbyists Peck Madigan Jones to
lobby the House and Senate they have
significantly funded this federal
lobbying spending Dominion voting
systems now owned by a hedge fund based
in New York City also started federal
lobbying this year with Brownstein Hyatt
Farber and Shrek a different lobbying
firm many of the lobbyists working for
both of these companies have donated to
Mitch McConnell's campaign and to Mitch
McConnell's joint fundraising committee
so listen can we prove that Mitch
McConnell is blocking election security
bills because of the donations from
voting machine lobbyists no that's not
the point and that's by design that's
how the system is designed even if there
isn't actual provable foul play here
this is a corrupt system that it is even
legal for voting machine companies that
tally election results to go and donate
money to elected officials who are
participating in those elections which
may be tallied by their voting machines
is a sickening but legal status quo in
the way things work in this country last
segment I said we have over
criminalization in the street crime
world in the United States we have under
criminalization and under prosecution
and under conviction and under
penalisation of white collar corporate
and political crime in the United States
Mitch McConnell is one of the most
insidious forces in American politics
today and he has been for years and very
successfully so for Republicans his role
in helping Republicans control the
courts including his amazingly
successful if you're a Republican
obstruction of Obama's Supreme Court
nominee Merrick garland extremely
successful from the point of view of
Republicans his continued involvement in
covering up the full true
in the Moller report as we saw from day
one after the bar letter was released
and now standing in the way
regularly of election security this guy
has got to go there are unfortunately no
serious challengers right now on the
basis of polling at taking him down in
Kentucky I know that there was at least
one declared candidate that candidate
from the polling I've seen is not
standing any chance at this point in
time this guy's got to go and as much as
we need to get rid of Trump Mitch
McConnell has become an extremely
effective I don't even know what to call
him
he's been an extremely effective
operative for some of the bigger
Republican successes over the last 10
years it's disgusting and most of it is
legal we have a voicemail number that
number is two one nine two david p i got
a bunch of voicemails in the last 24
hours
accusing me of d platforming fellow
progressive host sam cedar like i don't
even understand what they're talking
about listen to this what up DP longtime
fan here i've been listening to before
you hit puberty was listening to you
when you came out that you weren't gay
quite sad about that actually but I'm
actually calling kind of upset you deep
pop for my boy Sam cedar and we need to
figure out why my platform so I'm hoping
you're willing to address that situation
a D platform in Sam cedar this is Jason
from the 707 I don't know what this
guy's talking about and here's another
one hey David I don't know if you saw
the Sam cedar show today but he totally
talked about you he said that you are by
not showing his entire clip you totally
deep platformed him bro right so I think
you should totally respond to that and
then we'll see what Sam has to say to
defend himself against your be
platforming keep up the fight yeah I
don't know I mean listen I I think that
this is maybe someone coming to tattle
to me about sam cedars response to to
someone else tattling about tattling or
the
this point it's like a endless it it's
like those Russian matryoshka dolls I
don't know how else to describe it I
don't know what is going on I don't know
anything about deep platforming Sam
cedar I don't know what these people are
talking about but I will try to check
out that clip we've got a great bonus
show for you today we'll talk about the
new New York City tenant law that has
landlords very very fired up I also want
to talk about a division within the
Democratic Party about whether they
should give themselves the 2.6 percent
cost-of-living raise that they are due
in January and I also want to talk about
Ted Cruz apparently wants to team up
with Alexandria Castillo Cortez to make
birth control available over the counter
but this is actually a stealth
free-market conservative move doesn't
mean we should oppose it if it's the
right thing to make birth control
available over the counter without a
prescription then it should be but I do
want to explain to you what Ted Cruz's
ulterior motives are because they are
exactly what you would imagine them to
be get instant access to the bonus show
by becoming a member at WWE pakman.com
or become a patron at patreon.com slash
david pakman show
the david pakman show at david
pakman.com
[Music]
you